>> Martha: IF I LEFT
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ GETTING
HECKLED, SHOUTED DOWN BY FORMER
SUPPORTERS.
FURIOUS OVER THE DEMOCRATS
SUPPORT FOR SENDING MILITARY AID
TO UKRAINE.
>> NUCLEAR WAR, WHY ARE YOU
PLAYING WITH THE LIVES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS?
>> YOU HAVE DONE NOTHING.
I BELIEVED IN YOU, AND YOU
BECAME THE VERY THING THAT WE
FOUGHT AGAINST.
WHY NOT RIGHT NOW?
>> Martha: GREG, THEY WERE NOT
CLOSE ENOUGH TO MAKE HER EYES
WATER, BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS ALWAYS FUN TO SEE A
LEFTIST YELL AT A LEFTIST, BUT
THERE IS AN INTERESTING FLIP
GOING ON WHERE HARD-CORE
LEFTISTS ARE IN BED WITH THE
HOCKS, AND THEN YOU ARE SEEING
THE RIOTS TRY TO SLOW THE ROLE.
THE ODDS OF A NUCLEAR EVENT AT
25%.
MAYBE IT IS JUST GOING TO LOOK
LIKE THAT AND WILL NOT HAPPEN,
BUT YOU WOULD THINK EVERYONE
WOULD PUT THAT AT THE VERY TOP
OF THEIR LIST, PREVENTING GLOBAL
EXTINCTION, RIGHT?
BUT IF YOU MENTION PEACE OR
NEGOTIATION, YOU WILL BE GRANTED
BY THE HARD LEFT AS BEING A
PROPAGANDIST OR A PUTIN LOVER,
SO IT IS KIND OF ODD TO SEE
PEOPLE, FOR EXAMPLE, YESTERDAY,
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE, THE EARTH IS
GOING TO BE DESTROYED, BUT THEY
ARE OKAY -- THEY ARE NOT EVEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS.
IT'S KIND OF NUTS.
>> Martha: ABSOLUTELY.
SOME OF THAT COMES FROM THE
ATTITUDE OF CONSERVATIVES FOR
TRUMP, DOESN'T IT?
>> Jesse: HE AWAKENED AN
ISOLATIONIST AREA OF THE PARTY.
GOOD FOR BOTH PARTIES TO
QUESTION SOME OF THE MORE HAWKS
THAT RUN THINGS, BUT THERE IS NO
MORE PRINCIPLED LEFT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE PRINCIPLED ANTIWAR LEFT IS
GONE.
HE SAW THAT DURING THE COLD WAR.
EAST SIDE DURING THE FIRST
GULF WAR.
IRAQ WAR, OBVIOUSLY.
AND THEN -- AND THEN, YOU
REMEMBER YOU HAD PEOPLE LIKE AOC
DURING THE STRIKE, THEY WERE
LIKE THAT IS A WAR CRIME.
OR ANYTHING TRUMP DID
INTERNATIONALLY.
IT WAS A WAR CRIME.
AND THEN BIDEN IS JUST FEEDING
THE WAR MACHINE OVER UKRAINE
HERE DON'T EVEN NEED TO DEBATE
THAT.
BUT SHE IS JUST WRITING CHECKS
FROM THE TREASURY.
GO FOR IT.
UNLEASH THE WAR MACHINE.
AND USUALLY YOU HAVE PEOPLE ON
NOT FAR LEFT WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY DON'T WANT ANY -- THEY WANT
PEACE.
THAT IS OVER IT.
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
HAROLD IS LOOKING AT ME LIKE
"NOT IN MY HOUSE," BUT THOSE
DAYS ARE OVER.
YOU NEED THAT ON BOTH SIDES.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE ONLY PEOPLE
REALLY QUESTIONING THE WAR
EFFORT ARE REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE NOT SAYING -- THEY ARE
JUST SAYING WHAT ARE WE DOING
HERE?
IS THIS IN OUR INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY?
>> Martha: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
AOC GETTING YELLED AT?
SHE DID SIT IN NANCY PELOSI'S
OFFICE, SO SHE IS GETTING A
LITTLE DOSE OF --
>> Dana: I THINK SHE DOES NOT
KNOW HOW TO ANSWER IT.
PRECISELY WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, THAT THERE IS NO PEACE
MOVEMENT IN AMERICA, AND ANYONE
WHO SAYS WAIT A MINUTE -- AND I
HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE
MILITARY.
OFFSTAGE, THEY WILL SAY YEAH, WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHERE THIS
THING IS ACTUALLY GOING.
HIT THE REWIND BUTTON.
REMEMBER THAT THE FIRST THING WE
OFFERED ZELENSKY WAS A RIDE OUT.
WE SAID YOU ARE GOING TO GET
CRUSHED BY RUSSIA.
THIS IS GOING TO BE UGLY.
WE GIVE YOU SO MUCH CREDIT FOR
YOUR DESIRE TO SAVE YOUR
COUNTRY, TO BUILD AN ARMY, BUT
YOU CAN DO IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET CRUSHED.
WE WILL HELP YOU OUT, TAKING
INTO EXILE, THINK OF THIS WHOLE
THING OUT.
LOOK WHAT HE DID.
HE STUNNED THE WORLD WITH HIS
ABILITY TO STAND UP TO PUTIN,
WHICH OF COURSE EVERYONE
ADMIRES, BUT WE ARE GETTING
PULLED IN MORE AND MORE BECAUSE
WE SAID YOU ARE INCREDIBLE.
OF COURSE WE SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING, WE HAVE NOT HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON AND SAID OKAY, WHERE IS
THIS GOING?
WE JUST GOT OUT OF A 20 YEAR WAR
IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY BOTH SAID NO MORE, WE ARE
NOT DOING THIS ANYMORE, SO I
JUST RAISE A QUESTION, AND I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER, WHAT ARE
WE DOING?
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
FOR HOW LONG?
HOW SOON UNTIL WE HAVE OUR OWN
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS IS
GOING, BUT I THINK IT'S GOOD TO
ASK THE QUESTION.
>> Martha: I CAN TELL YOU
WHERE IT'S NOT GOING.
WE ARE NOT DOING EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER APPEARED GOES BACK TO
PRODUCING AS MUCH -- STAR
VLADIMIR PUTIN OF MONEY AND
MANPOWER, AND WE ARE NOT DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE COULD TO DO
IT.
WE'VE GOT TO START WITH THAT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION OF
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
JUST LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I SPOKE BEFORE OR AFTER
JOE BIDEN HALF A DOZEN TIMES,
AND THE FACT IS WHEN HE CAME UP
THAT STAGE, YOU KNOW IF PEOPLE
WERE NOT SAYING?
THAT GUY HAS THE ENERGY, THE
VIGOR, VIGOR, ALL OF A SUDDEN HE
DEVELOPS IT.
>> YOU ARE MISSING THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
WHEN WE MOVED TO REAL DEMOCRATS,
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE SOUTH,
THEY LOVED HIM, STEAMROLLED
EVERYBODY.
IN MY PARTY, THE HEART AND SOUL
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR, NOT WHITE
LIBERALS ON TWITTER.
SORRY TO USE BAD LANGUAGE.
>> I JUST WANTED TO LIVEN IT UP
A LITTLE BIT.
>> I DO THINK -- I PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE SET IT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED, DEMOCRATS WE
HAVE ELECTED PRESIDENT, HE LOST
THOSE EARLY STATES.
NOT UNTIL HE GOT TO
SUPER TUESDAY AND HAD
SOUTH CAROLINA, GEORGIA,
NORTH CAROLINA, TEXAS, WITH
HISPANIC AND BLACK DEMOCRATS,
OBVIOUSLY THE SAME HAPPENED WITH
JOE BIDEN, BARACK OBAMA, WHO
EXPERIENCED SUCCESS IN IOWA, WON
AND SOUTH CAROLINA.
BLACK VOTERS ARE CREDIBLE TO THE
PARTY.
I WOULD SAY IT IS JUST VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT UKRAINE.
WE DO NOT HAVE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND THERE.
WE HAVE SENT ARMS TO THESE
PEOPLE.
WE CANNOT HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
WE CANNOT SAY GOSH, SO GLAD YOU
ARE FIGHTING.
DON'T FIGHT TOO MUCH NOW BECAUSE
HE WILL MAKE US UNCOMFORTABLE.
WE WANT TO CONTROL OUR FUTURE.
WE WOULD RATHER DIE ON OUR
KNEES -- DIE ON OUR FEET THAN
LIVE ON OUR KNEES.
I ADMIRE THAT.
IF WE HAD TROOPS THERE, I THINK
IT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION.
I'M ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE
CONGRESSWOMAN -- WE TALKED ABOUT
HER MAYBE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HER POLITICS ARE NOT MINE, BUT
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
EXPERIENCES YOU HAVE TO HAVE.
THOSE THAT YOU BELIEVE IN, YOUR
ALLIES, CHALLENGE YOU.
STAND UP FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE
IN.
IF YOU VOTED FOR SOMETHING,
STAND UP FOR IT.
SAY YOU MADE A MISTAKE IF YOU
MADE A MISTAKE.
THINK OF WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED, HAD WE NOT SUPPORTED
THEM.
THINK ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO
GAVE A SPEECH NONE MONTHS AGO,
SAYING I WANT TO RECONSTITUTE
THE SOVIET UNION.
THIS WOULD NOT ONLY DESTABILIZE
EASTERN EUROPE, BUT A GREAT
THREAT TO OUR FRIENDS AND ALLIES
IN NATO.
>> Jesse: IF SHE BELIEVES WHAT
YOU SAID, SHE SHOULD HAVE SAID
THAT WHEN SHE GOT HECKLED.
>> Martha: SO RUDE.
INTERRUPTING SUPPORTERS.
>> Harold: POLITICS IS NOT A
SPECTATOR SPORT.
I DON'T CARE IF I DISAGREE WITH
YOU.
WE DISAGREE WITH THINGS, BUT I
LOVE WHEN SOMEONE HAS A
POSITION, ABLE TO DEFEND THEIR
POSITION.
THAT IS WHAT YOU RESPECT, AND I
HOPE THAT THE CONGRESSWOMAN IS
ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> Martha: BASICALLY SAYING IT
IS NOT THE LEADERS WHERE THE
PROBLEM, IS THE VOTERS.
WE HAVE BAD FOLLOWERS, NOT BAD
LEADER